so check this out this is tom selleck
i i know who he is i'm saying it for the
audience
okay that's like i know that is i'm
saying it for the audience
[Laughter]
tom selleck the king of the mustaches
what do you think he's plugging it's
gotta be
i'm gonna guess he's at that age now it
has to be something with
the aarp it has to be like a gold
birch capital sam waterston type
commercial
it's gonna be one of those reverse
mortgage
and this is the most i don't know
well i'm just gonna play it how about i
just play it's gonna be evil
he's look this isn't my first rodeo
and let me tell you something i wouldn't
be here
if i thought reverse mortgages took
advantage of
any american senior he can't or worse
that it was some way to take your home
it's already starting off with saying
so they're going to take your home if
you don't get a reverse mortgage
well what he's saying at the beginning
of this he's saying because there's a
lot of criticism and i think rightfully
so for reverse mortgages
that they are predatory yeah
so that's why he starts with look
this isn't my first rodeo and let me
tell you something
i wouldn't be here if i thought reverse
mortgages
took advantage of any american senior
or worse that it was some way to take
your home
it's just a loan and somebody earlier
pointed out as i played this on dave
pointed out like it's not a way to take
your home it's way to take your
children's home
designed for older homeowners and it's
helped
over a million americans a reverse
mortgage loan isn't some kind of trick
to take your home
it's alone like any other look i don't
know how many times i got to say this
it's not a trick to take your [ __ ]
home i was magnum p.i would i [ __ ]
lie to you people
that's my point like who who are you
arguing with
there's nobody else in this commercial
but you it's not a scam royce
get it through your head okay now give
us your money
give us your home we'll give you a
couple of buckaroonies
big difference is how you pay it back
find out how reverse mortgages really
work
with aag's free no obligation reverse
mortgage guide
eliminate monthly mortgage payments pay
bills medical costs and more
it's totally not a scam it's not a way
to take your home remember jack
call now and get your free info kit with
a picture of magnum pi on it
[Laughter]
100-747-4294 other mortgages
are paid each month but with a reverse
mortgage you can pay whatever you can
when it works for you or you can wait
until we take it
home wait and pay it off and one lump
sum is what he's going to say or until
you die and your children have to pay
one lobster and guess what they can't
because you were dumb and you went on
too many rv trips
and you left beyond a horrible debt to
income ratio
so now your kids have to sell the home
isn't that awesome
but hey you always said you wanted them
to pick themselves up by their
bootstraps and what better way
than making them buy a 600 000 home
instead of inheriting the five hundred
thousand dollar home that you bought for
four grand in the sixties
hey i'm magnum p.i i wouldn't be
shilling this product
if i thought it was evil whatever you
can when it works for you
or you can wait and pay it off in one
lump sum when you leave your home
discover the option that's best what's
going to be next when they start pushing
drugs on people is it going to be
[ __ ]
hi i'm sam waterston from law order and
i wouldn't be pushing this vaccine if i
didn't do lab testing myself and i was
like
you did but you didn't though call today
and find out more in aag's free no
obligation reverse mortgage loan guide
access tax-free cash and stay in the
home you love
you've probably been investing in your
home for years
making monthly mortgage payments doing
the right thing
and it's become your family's heart and
soul
well that investment can give you
tax-free cash
just when you need it it's so
[ __ ] evil there's a reason why i've
always been obsessed with
specifically this financial product it
makes me
sick i've worked in loan mod
offices back in the day and i've worked
in like those kind of little boiler
i've seen these predatory products and
it's
i've seen the people that it's marketed
to
who are by the way [ __ ] yokels these
are not you know i mean
these aren't they're not swindling
doctors out of their mansions
you know what i mean these are [ __ ]
morons that like have
tiny little homes that are old they're
on a fixed income and they're like
oh boy i talked to a banker today and he
said he was gonna make it all work for
me
and it's like no grandma don't sign
anything you didn't sign the [ __ ]
grandma you didn't sign that form that
had a picture of magnum pi on it did you
yeah i already put it in the mailbox
like i'm driving over there right now
i'm
crashing into your mailbox owners are
strategically using a reverse mortgage
loan to cover expenses
pay for health care preserve your
portfolio and so much more
look reverse mortgages aren't for
everyone
but i think i've been around long enough
to know what's what
i'm proud to be a part of aag
i trust them i think you can too
trust aag for the best reverse mortgage
solutions
call 1-800-747-4252 can i give real
advice
right now to the people out there if
you're older and your
bills are piling up and you're scared
and you're you don't know what to do
this is my advice to you not real advice
don't take this
advice full disclaimer this isn't really
advice i'm just doing a bit
but if you're old your income's
limited now and your your bills are
racking up if you're
anything older than let's say 70 just
don't pay anything
track your credit up and don't pay any
of it
they can't take your home they can't
it's they can't take your primary
residence that's the beauty of that so
just rack up your credit you don't have
to take a loan out against your house
sign new paperwork that that that agrees
to give that house to your
to the bank it's like an extra way of
tricking you right now you have to give
him your house
just run your credit up like a goddamn
lunatic if you're done especially if you
know like you've got maybe five ten good
years left
dude give your credit card out like give
a credit card to your kid and just let
them go
buy some [ __ ] who care don't pay it they
can't take the home from the kids
they'll still get the home you know what
i mean but when you do a reverse
mortgage
that's it your family's legacy is gone
stop it